Have you ever tried BBQ on BBQ? Picture this. Freshly prepared crispy seasoned chicken that's tossed in a smoky barbecue glaze and topped with a creamy barbecue sauce. Can't picture it? Well you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new BBQ crispy chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. The 7th of May 2005 began as a typical run of the mill day for Shirley Withers. She worked the full day in her fashion boutique and once the shop had closed she bought a takeout meal and then headed to a boyfriend's house in Caulfield in Melbourne, Australia. But what she found when she arrived there about 7pm was anything but run of the mill. I had so much trouble with this money. This money really is a thrill. This is for anybody after this. This is for that tiny 60 cent. Peter Shellard was a 56 year old self made millionaire. He lived in a luxury North Caulfield mansion worth about $6 million at the time.
你试过在烧烤上吃烧烤吗？设想一下：新鲜出炉、外脆里嫩的调味鸡肉，裹上烟熏烧烤釉料，再盖上奶油烧烤酱。想象不出来？现在你可以在蒂姆餐厅品尝到了。快来限时品尝我们全新的烧烤脆鸡碗和卷饼。2005年5月7日，对雪莉·威瑟斯（Shirley Withers）来说，只是平淡无奇的一天。她在自己的时装精品店工作了一整天，打烊后买了一份外卖，然后前往位于澳大利亚墨尔本考菲尔德（Caulfield）的男友家。但当她在晚上7点左右到达那里时，发现的事物却一点也不普通。我为这笔钱遇到了这么多麻烦。这笔钱真的太刺激了。这是给任何想要这个的人准备的。这是为了那微不足道的60美分。彼得·谢拉德（Peter Shellard）是一位56岁的白手起家百万富翁。当时他住在考菲尔德北部一栋价值约600万美元的豪华豪宅里。
He was the type of person that everybody had a story about. He was described as a bit of an oddball, a little bit out there. Many referred to him as the eccentric millionaire. And he lived up to that tag when he appeared on the Today Tonight TV show and outlined his plans to purchase the entire Rolls Royce factory worth about $16 billion. He said in that interview, well I probably am a bit mad, but it's nice to be a bit mad, isn't it? He made this fortune in real estate and then he bought into a successful high-end car dealership specialising in BMWs, Jaguars and his favourite Rolls Royce. He ended up being the director of several companies and would go on to own numerous residential and commercial properties. At the time of his death his estate was estimated to be worth around $15 million. Not only was Peter a successful businessman, he was known to be a ruthless businessman. He wasn't the type of person you would want to get on the wrong side of. He never resorted to violence. His method of battle was to try and financially cripple people. He would file lawsuits at the drop of a hat.
他是那种每个人都有故事的人。他被描述为一个有点古怪、有点特立独行的人。许多人称他为古怪的百万富翁。当他出现在《今日今夜》（Today Tonight）电视节目中并概述他计划购买价值约160亿美元的整个劳斯莱斯工厂时，他确实不负这个称号。他在那次采访中说，嗯，我可能有点疯狂，但疯狂一点也挺好，不是吗？他靠房地产发家，然后买下了一家成功的高档汽车经销店，专门经营宝马、捷马和他的最爱劳斯莱斯。他最终成为多家公司的董事，并拥有众多住宅和商业地产。在他去世时，他的房产估计价值约1500万美元。彼得不仅是一位成功的商人，还以冷酷无情著称。他不是那种你想惹上麻烦的人。他从不诉诸暴力。他的战斗方法是试图让人陷入财务困境。他动不动就提起诉讼。
If there was a problem, Peter was suing. In the year 2000, Peter, aged 51 at the time, met Shirley Withers, who was 33 years old. Shirley isn't the type of woman you picture a multi-millionaire property developer and luxury car dealer going for. She wasn't your glamour type, so to speak. Regardless, Peter was smitten when he first met Shirley. Peter had previously been married twice and had three daughters. Shirley herself had been divorced once and had two sons. Their relationship blossomed and moved quickly. All of a sudden Shirley found herself in a completely new lifestyle filled with every luxury she could imagine. Peter was smitten, so whatever Shirley wanted, she got. Peter bought her an upmarket fashion boutique in the Melbourne suburb of Brighton. Shirley ran the business, but Peter financed everything.
只要有问题，彼得就会起诉。2000年，时年51岁的彼得遇到了33岁的雪莉·威瑟斯。雪莉并不是那种你想象中身家数百万的房地产开发商兼豪车经销商会追求的女性。用通俗的话说，她不是那种迷人的类型。尽管如此，彼得在第一次见到雪莉时就坠入爱河了。彼得以前结过两次婚，有三个女儿。雪莉自己离过一次婚，有两个儿子。他们的关系迅速升温。突然之间，雪莉发现自己置身于一个充满她能想象到的各种奢华的全新生活方式中。彼得深陷爱河，所以雪莉想要什么，就能得到什么。彼得在墨尔本布莱顿（Brighton）郊区为她买了一家高档时装精品店。雪莉经营这家店，但一切都由彼得出资。
And it wasn't long before Peter had another surprise for Shirley, a brand new house. Being divorced twice, Peter was in no hurry to move in together, so he stayed living in his Caulfield mansion, and Shirley could have her own house to live in. Shirley of course had a key for Peter's mansion and vice versa. Shirley was a bookkeeper, so Peter decided to make use of her skills. He put her in charge of the books at his luxury car dealership. On the 7th of May 2005, Shirley withers spent the full day working in her fashion boutique in Brighton. At the end of the day, she finished up all the book work, bought a takeout meal, and then headed to Peter's mansion in Caulfield. When she walked inside, she found Peter dead on the floor. He had been tied up with dog leashes, electrical cords and ropes. His mouth had been gagged shut. That's when Shirley made that frantic triple local.
没过多久，彼得给雪莉准备了另一个惊喜：一栋崭新的房子。由于离过两次婚，彼得并不急于同居，所以他继续住在他的考菲尔德豪宅里，而雪莉可以有自己的房子住。雪莉当然有彼得豪宅的钥匙，反之亦然。雪莉是一名簿记员，所以彼得决定利用她的技能。他让她负责其豪车经销店的账目。2005年5月7日，雪莉·威瑟斯在布莱顿的时装精品店工作了一整天。一天结束时，她做完了所有的账目工作，买了一份外卖，然后前往彼得在考菲尔德的豪宅。当她走进去时，她发现彼得死在地板上。他被狗链、电线和绳子捆绑着。他的嘴被勒住了。就在那时，雪莉拨打了那个疯狂的紧急求救电话。
Detectives arrived soon after, and they were confronted with one of the most bizarre crime scenes they had ever seen. They looked more like a movie set than real life. It's here that the secret world of Peter Shellard started to make a very public appearance. There was a great deal of bondage equipment at the scene. There were leather masks, leather outfits, whips, dog leads, chains, harnesses, belts and other equipment. The initial impression of the crime scene was that it appeared to be a sexual encounter that had gone horribly wrong. Peter had bruising all around his body as well as facial injuries. Had somebody gone too far?
侦探们不久后抵达现场，展现在他们眼前的是他们见过的最离奇的犯罪现场之一。这里看起来更像是一个电影布景，而不是现实生活。正是在这里，彼得·谢拉德的秘密世界开始公诸于世。现场有大量的捆绑调教设备。有皮面具、皮衣、皮鞭、狗链、铁链、安全带、皮带和其他设备。犯罪现场给人的第一印象似乎是一场出了可怕差错的性爱遭遇。彼得全身都有瘀伤以及面部受伤。是不是有人玩得过火了？
A thorough examination of the crime scene was conducted, and the police were in luck. A bloody fingerprint was found on Peter's home phone, and a cigarette butt was found in the kitchen. Did these belong to Peter, or were they turning out to be vodal clues? Unfortunately, there was no way of knowing straight away. Detectives would have to wait until the results came back from the lab, which could take a little while. In the meantime, they had to get to work to find out what exactly happened to Peter. The first obvious person to question was Shirley Withers, Peter's girlfriend. She had found Peter dead and made the frantic emergency telephone call.
对犯罪现场进行了彻底检查后，警方运气不错。在彼得家里的电话上发现了一个带血的指纹，在厨房里发现了一个烟头。这些是彼得的，还是会成为关键线索？不幸的是，无法立即得知。侦探们必须等待实验室的结果出来，这可能需要一段时间。与此同时，他们必须开始工作，查明彼得到底发生了什么。第一个显而易见的讯问对象是彼得的女友雪莉·威瑟斯。她发现了彼得的尸体并拨打了紧急求救电话。
They asked her about Peter's interest in bondage, but she was unable to offer them too much information. Peter had asked her to participate in bondage previously, but she declined. Shirley told detectives Peter respected her decision and didn't pursue it any further with her. She was completely oblivious to any acts of bondage Peter was participating in. Detectives discovered that Shirley stood to gain nothing out of Peter's death. With the exception of $1 each, he left to each of his two ex-wives. Peter's entire estate was left to his daughters. This removed a very big, very common motive for murder.
他们询问了彼得对捆绑调教的兴趣，但她无法提供太多信息。彼得以前曾邀请她参与捆绑，但她拒绝了。雪莉告诉侦探，彼得尊重她的决定，并没有再跟她深入探讨。她对彼得参与的任何捆绑行为一无所知。侦探们发现，彼得的死对雪莉没有任何好处。除了留给两个前妻每人1美元外，彼得的全部遗产都留给了他的女儿们。这就消除了一个非常重大、非常普遍的谋杀动机。
As far as detectives could tell, Shirley had no other motive to harm him. She appeared shocked and heartbroken, and her actions didn't raise suspicion at all. Detectives started to look elsewhere for motive and opportunity. Despite what the crime scene looked like, they weren't completely sold on the theory that Peter had died as a result of a bondage session gone wrong. They were more than open to the possibility that the crime scene had been staged to make it look that way. They started diving into Peter's past business relationships and looking at the long list of people Peter had filed lawsuits against. Despite the thinking being there was a long list of people with a reason to harm Peter, detectives really didn't find anything significant.
据侦探们所知，雪莉没有其他伤害他的动机。她显得震惊而心碎，她的行为根本没有引起怀疑。侦探们开始在其他地方寻找动机和机会。尽管犯罪现场看起来是那样，但他们并不完全相信彼得是因为一次出错的捆绑调教而死的。他们完全有可能接受犯罪现场是被伪装成那样的可能性。他们开始深入调查彼得过去的商业关系，并查看了彼得起诉过的一长串人员名单。尽管人们认为有一长串人有理由伤害彼得，但侦探们并没有发现任何重大线索。
No obvious suspects jumped out at them. This led detectives to go back to the bondage gone wrong theory. And if this is what happened, they needed to establish who Peter's partner or partners were on the night of his death. Despite his partner Shirley saying that Peter hadn't pursued his interest in bondage any further with her, detectives soon found that it hadn't stopped Peter pursuing his interest in bondage elsewhere. He was very much into it. He had paid several visits to the Hellfire Club in Melbourne. At the Hellfire Club, you could do things such as get tied up, get whipped, have hot wax poured over you and so on.
没有明显的嫌疑人跳出来。这导致侦探们回到了捆绑出错的理论。如果事情就是这样，他们需要确定彼得当晚的伴侣是谁。尽管他的伴侣雪莉说彼得没有再跟她追求他对捆绑的兴趣，但侦探们很快发现这并没有阻止彼得在其他地方追求他对捆绑的兴趣。他对此非常热衷。他曾多次访问墨尔本的炼狱俱乐部（Hellfire Club）。在炼狱俱乐部，你可以做一些事情，比如被绑起来、被鞭打、被浇上热蜡等等。
Alternatively, you could do these things to somebody else if you so desired. This was useful information, but again, detectives still couldn't come up with any suspects from the bondage angle. A few days later, the autopsy result came back and it would have a major impact on the investigation. It was found that Peter suffered repeated blunt force trauma to the head, resulting in a fractured skull. And not only that, Peter's body had been pumped full of heroin. Peter wasn't a user of heroin. In fact, he wasn't a user of drugs at all. He was known to be quite anti-drugs. The theory that he may have died as a result of an overzealous bondage session was shot out of the water. It was clear Peter had been deliberately beaten and then given a hot shot, a hit of heroin designed to kill.
或者，如果你愿意的话，你可以对别人做这些事。这是有用的信息，但侦探们仍然无法从捆绑的角度找出任何嫌疑人。几天后，尸检结果出来了，这对调查产生了重大影响。结果发现，彼得头部多次受到钝器创伤，导致头骨骨折。不仅如此，彼得体内被注入了大量海洛因。彼得不是海洛因使用者。事实上，他根本不是毒品使用者。众所周知，他相当反对毒品。他可能是因为过度热心的捆绑调教而死的理论被彻底推翻了。很明显，彼得是被蓄意殴打，然后被注射了致命剂量的海洛因。
There was now no doubt, somebody had intended to kill Peter. And it wasn't long after this, the detectives got the break in the investigation. They had matched the bloody fingerprint and it didn't belong to Peter. The fingerprint matched a girl by the name of Sophia Stupas. Not only that, her DNA was found on the cigarette that had been left in the kitchen. Sophia was known to police. So was her boyfriend, Stanley. They were small-time petty criminals and known drug addicts. They were both particularly fond of heroin.
现在毫无疑问，有人蓄意谋杀彼得。不久之后，侦探们在调查中取得了突破。他们比对带血的指纹，发现它不属于彼得。指纹与一个名叫索菲亚·斯图帕斯（Sophia Stupas）的女孩相匹配。不仅如此，在留在厨房的烟头上也发现了她的DNA。索菲亚是警方熟知的人物。她的男友斯坦利（Stanley）也是。他们是小偷小摸的惯犯和众所周知的吸毒者。他们俩都特别喜欢海洛因。
But despite their long criminal records, neither was known for violence. It was all drugs and property theft type stuff to support their drug habit. But what was interesting for police was that Sophia had a history in bondage. Police knew this after bondage equipment was found at a place during a police raid that had been conducted previously for an unrelated matter. Sophia had definitely been at the crime scene and wherever Sophia went, Stanley was usually there as well. Their involvement could explain both the bondage angle and the heroin angle. Police now had their prime suspects. But as detectives were getting ready to make their move on Sophia and Stanley, the case took an unexpected twist.
但尽管他们有很长的犯罪记录，但两人都不是以暴力闻名。这都是为了支持他们吸毒习惯的毒品和财产盗窃之类的东西。但对警方来说有趣的是，索菲亚有捆绑调教的背景。警方在之前因无关事项进行的一次突袭行动中在一个地方发现了捆绑设备后才得知这一点的。索菲亚绝对去过犯罪现场，而且索菲亚去哪儿，斯坦利通常也在那儿。他们的参与可以解释捆绑角度和海洛因角度。警方现在有了主要嫌疑人。但正当侦探们准备对索菲亚和斯坦利采取行动时，案件发生了意想不到的转折。
A telephone call had just been intercepted by police and this telephone call had massive significance for the murder investigation. A contract had just been put out for the lives of Sophia and Stanley. While they both had long criminal records, they were small-time, low-level drug addicts, petty criminals. They didn't mix in the circles where people put hits out on each other. But it turns out it wasn't fellow criminals that wanted them dead. The hit was ordered by Shirley Withers. This raised some very interesting questions. How the hell did Shirley Withers know Sophia and Stanley were involved in Peter's death?
警方刚刚截获了一通电话，这通电话对谋杀案调查具有重大意义。刚刚有人对索菲亚和斯坦利发出了谋杀契约。虽然他们都有很长的犯罪记录，但他们只是小打小闹、底层的瘾君子和小毛贼。他们不涉足雇凶杀人的圈子。但事实证明，想要他们死的人并不是同案犯。谋杀令是雪莉·威瑟斯下达的。这提出了几个非常有趣的问题。雪莉·威瑟斯到底是怎么知道索菲亚和斯坦利参与了彼得的谋杀的？
Had somebody leaked the information to her? Or did Shirley know more than she was letting on? Either way, detectives had to find out. So they sent in Victor the hitman. It was of course not a real hitman. He was an undercover police officer. Victor tells Shirley that he can do the job for $10,000. But he needs photos of them and their addresses.
有人把消息泄露给她了吗？还是雪莉知道的比她透露的要多？无论如何，侦探们必须查明真相。于是他们派出了杀手维克托（Victor）。这当然不是真正的杀手。他是一名便衣警察。维克托告诉雪莉，他可以以1万美元的价格完成这项工作。但他需要他们的照片和地址。
Shirley gave Victor this information handed over photos and a cash deposit. She said to Victor, They are the ones that killed my Peter and they have to pay for what they've done. I want blood. Detectives quickly made their move on Sophia and Stanley. Although Shirley had just hired a police officer to kill them, they weren't too sure if maybe she'd hired a second person as well. So they arrested them and took them back to the police station
雪莉把这些信息交给了维克托，交出了照片和现金押金。她对维克托说，他们是杀害我的彼得的人，他们必须为他们所做的事付出代价。我要血。侦探们迅速对索菲亚和斯坦利采取行动。尽管雪莉刚刚雇了一名警察去杀他们，但他们不太确定她是否也雇了第二个人。于是他们逮捕了他们，并把他们带回警察局
to find out exactly what they knew. During the initial stages of questioning, both of them deny having any knowledge about Peter's death. They put up the wall of silence. They put up the wall of silence. They put up the wall of silence. But that soon changed when police told them Shirley had just put a hit out on them. When they learnt that, they couldn't talk quick enough.
以查明他们到底知道什么。在讯问的初期，他们俩都否认对彼得的死有任何了解。他们筑起了一道沉默之墙。他们筑起了一道沉默之墙。他们筑起了一道沉默之墙。但当警方告诉他们雪莉刚刚对他们下达了追杀令时，情况很快就改变了。当他们得知这一点时，他们恨不得马上把一切都说出来。
They admitted to police that they were there the night that Peter died and they know what happened to him. But according to them, they weren't there alone. They both named a third person who was there with them. Detective started to take a much closer look at Shirley Willis. She was born in India before migrating to Australia. She suffered abuse at just nine years of age and this led her to develop post-traumatic stress disorder.
他们向警方承认，彼得死的那晚他们在场，并且他们知道彼得身上发生了什么。但据他们所言，他们当时并不是孤身一人。他们俩都说出了当时和他们在一起的第三个人的名字。侦探开始对雪莉·威利斯（Shirley Willis）进行更仔细的调查。她出生于印度，后来移民到澳大利亚。她在年仅九岁时遭受虐待，这导致她患上了创伤后应激障碍。
After the birth of her second son, she was in and out of hospital for over a year, suffering severe post-natal depression. And she ended up making three suicide attempts. Detective started going through the books of Shirley's high-end fashion boutique. From the outside looking in, everything seemed to suggest the shop was successful and doing quite well. But a closer look at the finances showed that the business was actually going backwards and was in significant debt.
在她第二个儿子出生后，她因严重的产后抑郁症进出医院一年多。她最终试图自杀三次。侦探开始查阅雪莉的高档时装精品店的账目。从外表上看，一切似乎都表明这家店很成功，经营得相当不错。但仔细一看财务状况，发现该业务实际上在走下坡路，并且背负着沉重的债务。
The business owed close to $300,000. The truth was Shirley had no idea how to run a business. She kept ordering high-end stock, despite not being able to sell the stock she currently had on hand. But it didn't worry her. She had Peter's large bank account to steal from. As detectives dug further, they found that Shirley had been stealing from Peter to keep the business afloat and to allow her to keep living the life of luxury she had become accustomed to.
这家店欠了近30万元。事实是，雪莉根本不知道如何经营业务。她不断订购高端库存，尽管她无法卖出现有的库存。但她并不担心。她可以偷彼得的巨额银行账户。随着侦探们的深入挖掘，他们发现雪莉一直在偷彼得的钱来维持业务运转，并让她继续过着她已经习惯的奢华生活。
She started writing checks to herself using Peter's bank account. In total, she stole around $900,000 from him. A few weeks before his death, Peter started to catch on to what Shirley had been doing. He called his accountant to check his books. His accountant told him there was more than enough evidence for Shirley to be charged. Peter was furious. He immediately froze Shirley out of all his accounts. Shirley's life was at risk.
她开始用彼得的银行账户给自己开支票。总共，她从他那里偷了大约90万元。在他死前几周，彼得开始察觉到雪莉一直在做的事情。他打电话给他的会计师查账。他的会计师告诉他，有足够的证据起诉雪莉。彼得大发雷霆。他立即冻结了雪莉的所有账户。雪莉的生命处于危险之中。
He had no idea what he was doing. He had no idea what he was doing. He froze Shirley out of all his accounts. Shirley's life of luxury had just come to an abrupt halt. Not only that, Peter put Shirley's house on the market. This stung Shirley and she started to formulate a plan to stop Peter from cutting her off. She befriended Stanley and Sophia. They came from a world far away from Shirley's upmarket lifestyle.
他根本不知道自己在做什么。他根本不知道自己在做什么。他冻结了雪莉的所有账户。雪莉的奢华生活戛然而止。不仅如此，彼得还把雪莉的房子挂牌出售。这刺痛了雪莉，她开始制定计划，阻止彼得切断对她的资助。她与斯坦利和索菲亚交朋友。他们来自一个远离雪莉高档生活方式的世界。
Shirley essentially groomed them for the job she had planned. She gave them thousands of dollars in cash in order to buy their friendship and trust. She also won them over with stories detailing how Peter forced her to participate in bondage sessions. She said that he tied her up and abused her. Stanley and Sophia lashed on. Shirley was throwing money at them and they saw her as an easy target. They would do whatever she wanted. Stanley and Sophia told police everything in their interviews.
雪莉本质上是为了她计划好的工作而培养他们。她给了他们数千元现金，以买通他们的友谊和信任。她还通过详细讲述彼得如何强迫她参与捆绑调教的故事赢得了他们的芳心。她说他把她绑起来并虐待她。斯坦利和索菲亚大发雷霆。雪莉向他们砸钱，他们把她看作一个容易下手的目标。他们会做她想要的任何事。斯坦利和索菲亚在采访中把一切都告诉了警方。
It became clear to them that Shirley had set them up and had planned all along for them to take the rap for Peter's murder. They both said they were of the belief that they were just going to rough Peter up for cutting off Shirley's money supplier and forced him to sign some documents for her. This included him signing the house she lived in over to her so we couldn't sell it. On the night of May 6th 2005 Shirley picked up Stanley and Sophia and drove over to Peter's house. Shirley still had a key to his place so they got in easily. They made their way to Peter's bedroom where he was found asleep. They immediately jumped on him and started the attack. During the initial struggle Peter was able to bite Sophia's finger which is what would cause the bloody fingerprint to be left later.
他们清楚地认识到，雪莉陷害了他们，并一直计划让他们为彼得的谋杀背黑锅。他们都表示，他们以为他们只是去教训一下彼得，因为彼得切断了雪莉的资金来源，并强迫他为她签署一些文件。这包括让他把她住的房子过户给她，这样他就不能卖掉了。2005年5月6日晚，雪莉接上斯坦利和索菲亚，开车来到彼得家。雪莉仍然有他家的钥匙，所以他们很轻松地进去了。他们径直走到彼得的卧室，发现他在睡觉。他们立刻扑上去开始袭击。在最初的挣扎中，彼得咬了索菲亚的手指，这就是后来留下血手印的原因。
Sophia responded by belting him over the head. Peter was knocked unconscious but he wasn't dead. They dragged him out of his bed down to the floor and tied him up. Shirley then injected Peter with heroin. They left the house but then Shirley returned the next day to give Peter another shot of heroin just to make sure he wouldn't wake up. Shirley then set the crime scene up to make it look as though Peter had been engaging in a bondage act. She went to work for the day then returned that night where she made that fake frantic triple O call. Police and emergency services.
索菲亚反击，猛击他的头部。彼得被打晕了，但他还没死。他们把他从床上拖到地板上并绑起来。然后雪莉给彼得注射了海洛因。他们离开了房子，但雪莉第二天又回来了，给彼得注射了另一剂海洛因，以确保他不会醒来。然后雪莉布置了犯罪现场，使其看起来像是彼得一直在进行捆绑行为。她去上班了一整天，然后当晚回来，拨打了那个虚假的疯狂急救电话。警察和紧急服务人员。
The police were also looking for a way to get him out of the house. They were also looking for a way to get him out of the house. They were also looking for a way to get him out of the house. They were also looking for a way to get him out of the house. Shirley made that fake frantic triple O call. Police and emergency services. There's blood everywhere, is that correct? Listen to me, is there blood everywhere?
警方还在寻找让他离开房子的方法。警方还在寻找让他离开房子的方法。警方还在寻找让他离开房子的方法。警方还在寻找让他离开房子的方法。雪莉拨打了那个虚假的疯狂急救电话。警察和紧急服务人员。到处都是血，对吗？听我说，到处都是血吗？
Is he conscious and breathing? So now it was the word of two drug addicted petty criminals against the word of an upmarket boutique shop owner. Shirley continued to deny she had any involvement in Peter's death. So police arranged for Victor the hitman to pay her another visit. And they struck gold. The undercover police and emergency services were looking for a way to get him out of the house. They were also looking for a way to get him out of the house. So they arranged for Victor the hitman to pay her another visit.
他有意识和呼吸吗？所以现在是两个吸毒成瘾的小毛贼的话对抗一个高档精品店老板的话。雪莉继续否认她与彼得的死有任何牵连。于是警方安排杀手维克托再次拜访她。他们赚大发了。便衣警察和紧急服务人员正在寻找让他离开房子的方法。他们还在寻找让他离开房子的方法。所以他们安排杀手维克托再次拜访她。
And they struck gold. The undercover police officer expertly got Shirley to confess her involvement in Peter's murder. Shirley was arrested soon after. I put it to you that you were in fact involved in the planning and execution of a plan that resulted in Peter Schillard's death. What do you say to that? I have no comment to make. Shirley refused to say anything to detectives. So Shirley withers ordered a hit on Sophia and Stanley so they wouldn't talk and implicate her in the murder.
他们赚大发了。便衣警察巧妙地让雪莉承认她参与了彼得的谋杀。雪莉不久后被捕。我向你提出，你实际上参与了导致彼得·谢拉德死亡的计划的策划和实施。你对此有何评论？我无可奉告。雪莉拒绝向侦探说任何话。所以雪莉·威瑟斯对索菲亚和斯坦利下了追杀令，这样他们就不会开口并把她牵连到谋杀案中。
Which is kind of ironic. Because they didn't start talking until they found out Shirley had put a hit out on them. Although to be fair it was still early days and it's doubtful they would have continued to stay silent about Shirley's involvement. They probably would have started to look for a deal at some stage. Sophia and Stanley both pled guilty to manslaughter. In exchange for testifying against Shirley they were both given reduced sentences of six years jail with a non-parallel period of three and a half years. Shirley pled guilty to hiring a hitman conspiring to kill Sophia and Stanley but pled not guilty to the murder of Peter. After a six-week trial Shirley was found guilty of murder and sentenced to 26 years in jail with a non-parallel period of 18 years.
这有点讽刺。因为直到他们发现雪莉对他们下了追杀令后，他们才开始开口。尽管公平地说，当时还为时过早，而且他们是否会继续对雪莉的牵连保持沉默值得怀疑。他们可能在某个时候开始寻找交易。索菲亚和斯坦利都对过失杀人罪表示认罪。作为交换，他们作证指控雪莉，两人的刑期都被减至六年，不得假释期三年半。雪莉承认犯有雇凶杀人、阴谋杀害索菲亚和斯坦利的罪行，但对谋杀彼得的罪行不认罪。经过为期六周的审判，雪莉被判谋杀罪名成立，判处26年监禁，不得假释期18年。
But Shirley thought she could do better so she appealed this sentence. She argued that it was never her intention to kill Peter and that she had merely wanted to teach him a lesson. She argued she had no way of knowing how much heroin would kill Peter. Despite the brutal and premeditated nature of the attack, the staging of the crime scene, her attempts to have the people she hired for the job killed so they couldn't talk, she managed to convince the appeal judges and have her charge downgraded from murder to manslaughter. Here's what one of the judges had to say. The evidence fell short in our view of establishing an intention to kill or cause serious injury. Even though in the weeks leading up to Peter's death Shirley had written a new will that she intended to get Peter to sign.
但雪莉认为她可以做得更好，于是她对这一判决提出了上诉。她辩称，她从来没有打算杀死彼得，她只是想给他一个教训。她辩称，她根本无法知道多少海洛因会杀死彼得。尽管袭击具有残酷和有预谋的性质、犯罪现场的伪装、她试图杀死她为这项工作雇佣的人以让他们闭嘴，但她成功地说服了上诉法官，并将她的指控从谋杀降为过失杀人。以下是其中一位法官的发言。在我们看来，证据不足以确定杀害或造成严重伤害的意图。尽管在彼得死前的几周里，雪莉写了一份新遗嘱，她打算让彼得签署。
The new will still left $1 each to Peter's ex-wives but left the remainder of his estate to Shirley. For her role in the brutal murder of Peter Shellard, Shirley Withers was sentenced to 13 years jail with a non-parallel period of just 9 years. She is eligible for release this year. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
新遗嘱仍然给彼得的前妻每人留了1美元，但将剩余的遗产留给雪莉。由于她在残酷谋杀彼得·谢拉德中的角色，雪莉·威瑟斯被判处13年监禁，不得假释期仅为9年。她今年有资格获释。你 本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。